mr. speaker yesterday an act of
terrorism tried to silence our democracy
but today we meet as normal as
generations have done before us and as
future generations will continue to do
to deliver a simple message we are not
afraid and our resolve will never waver
in the face of terrorism and we meet
here in the oldest of all Parliament's
because we know that democracy and the
values it entails will always prevail
those values free speech Liberty human
rights and the rule of law are embodied
here in this place but they are shared
by free people around the world a
terrorist came to the place where people
of all nationalities and cultures gather
to celebrate what it means to be free
and he took out his rage
indiscriminately against innocent men
women and children mr. speaker this was
an attack on free people everywhere and
on behalf of the British people I would
like to thank our friends and allies
around the world who have made it clear
that they stand with us at this time
what happened on the streets of
Westminster yesterday afternoon sickened
us all well there is an ongoing police
investigation the house will understand
that there are limits to what I can say
but having been updated by police and
security officials let me set out what
at this stage I can tell the house at
approximately 2:40 p.m. yesterday a
single attacker drove his vehicle at
speed in two innocent pedestrians who
were crossing Westminster Bridge killing
two people and injuring around 40 more
in addition to 12 Britons admitted to
hospital we know that the victims
include three French children two
Romanians 4 South Koreans one German one
pole one Irish one Chinese
one Italian one American and two Greeks
and we are in close contact with the
governments of the countries of all
those affected the injured also included
three police officers who were returning
from an event to recognize their bravery
two of those three remain in a serious
condition mr. speaker the attacker then
left the vehicle and approached a police
officer at carriage gates attacking that
officer with a large knife before he was
shot dead by an armed police officer
tragically as the house will no forty
eight-year-old PC Keith Palmer was
killed
PC Palmer had devoted his life to the
service of his country he had been a
member of the parliamentary and
diplomatic protection command for 15
years and a soldier in the Royal
Artillery before that he was a husband
and a father killed doing a job he loved
he was every inch a hero and his actions
will never be forgotten I know the whole
house will join me in sending our
deepest condolences to his family and to
the families and friends of all those
who've been killed or injured in
yesterday's awful attacks I know also
that the house will wish to thank all
those who acted with such speed and
professionalism yesterday to secure this
place and ensure we are able to meet as
we are doing today mr. speaker at 7:30
last night I chaired a meeting of the
government's Emergency Committee Cobra
and we'll have further briefings and
meetings with security officials today
the threat level to the UK has been set
at severe meaning attack is highly
likely for some time this is the second
highest threat level the highest level
critical means there is specific
intelligence that an attack is imminent
as there is no such intelligence the
independent Joint Terrorism analysis
center has decided that the threat level
will not change in the light of
yesterday's
mr. speaker the whole country will want
to know who was responsible for this
atrocity and the measures that we are
taking to strengthen our security
including here in Westminster a full
counterterrorism investigation is
already underway hundreds of our police
and security officers have been working
through the night to establish
everything possible about this attack
including its preparation motivation and
whether there were any associates
involved in its planning and while the
remain limits on what I can say at this
stage I can confirm that overnight the
police have searched six addresses and
made eight arrests in Birmingham and
London
Mr Speaker it is still believed that
this attacker acted alone and the police
have no reason to believe there are
imminent further attacks on the public
his identity is known to the police and
mi5 and when operational considerations
allow he will be publicly identified
what I can confirm is that the man was
British born and that some years ago he
was once investigated by mi5 in relation
to concerns about violent extremism he
was a peripheral figure the case is
historic he was not part of the current
intelligence picture there was no prior
intelligence of his intent or of the
plot intensive investigations continue
and as Acting Deputy Commissioner Rollie
confirmed last night our working
assumption is that the attacker was
inspired by Islamist ideology Mr Speaker
we know the threat from Islamist
terrorism is very real but while the
public should remain utterly vigilant
they should not and will not be cowed by
this threat
as Acting Deputy Commissioner Olli has
made clear we are stepping up policing
to protect communities across the
country and to reassure the public and
as a precautionary measure this will
mean increasing the number of patrols in
cities across the country with more
police and more armed police on the
streets since June 2013 our police
security and intelligence agencies have
successfully disrupted 13 separate
terrorist plots in Britain following the
2015 strategic defence and security
review we protected the police budgets
for counterterrorism and committed to
increase cross government spending on
counterterrorism by 30 percent in real
terms over the course of this Parliament
and over the next five years we will
invest an extra two and a half billion
in building our global security and
intelligence network employing over
1,900 additional staff at mi5 mi6 and
GCHQ and more than doubling our global
network of counterterrorism experts
working with priority countries across
Europe the Middle East Africa and Asia
mr. speaker in terms of security here in
Westminster we should be clear first of
all that an attacker attempted to break
into Parliament and to a shot dead
within 20 yards of the gate if his
intention was to gain access to this
building we should be clear that he did
not succeed the police heroically did
their job but as is routine the police
together with the house authoritative
ughing the security of the parliamentary
estate coordinate it with the Cabinet
Office who have responsibility for the
security measures in place around the
government secure zone all of us in this
house have a responsibility for the
security and safety of our staff and
advice is available for members who need
it mr. speaker yesterday we saw the
worst of humanity but we will remember
the best we will remember the
extraordinary efforts to save the life
of PC Keith Palmer including those by my
right honourable friend
the member for Bournemouth east and we
will remember the exceptional bravery of
our police security and emergency
services who once again ran towards the
danger even as they encouraged others to
move the other way on behalf of the
whole country I want to pay tribute to
them for the work they have been doing
to reassure the public treat the injured
and bring security back to the streets
of our capital city that they have lost
one of their own in yesterday's attack
only makes their calmness and
professionalism all the more remarkable
mr. speaker a lot has been said since
terror struck London yesterday much more
will be said in the coming days but the
greatest response lies not in the words
of politicians but in the everyday
actions of ordinary people for beyond
these walls today in scenes repeated in
towns and cities across the country
millions of people are going about their
days and getting on with their lives
the streets are as busy as ever the
offices fall the coffee shops and cafes
bustling as I speak millions will be
boarding trains and aeroplanes to travel
to London and to see for themselves the
greatest city on earth it is in these
actions millions of acts of normality
that we find the best response to
terrorism
a response that denies our enemies their
victory that refuses to let them win
that shows we will never give in a
response driven by that same spirit that
drove our husband and father to put
himself between us and our attacker and
to pay the ultimate price a response
that says to the men and women who
propagate this hate and evil you will
not defeat us mr. speaker let this be
the message from this house and this
nation today our values will prevail and
I commend this statement to the house
[Applause]